il faudra trouver dans ce débat 300
millions pour que le système soit
équilibre
les recettes complémentaires de que
proposent les républicains c'est par
exemple une convergence plus rapide sur
les régimes des régimes spéciaux avec le
régime général une façon de gagner de
l'argent assez rapidement j'entends bien
mais pour ce qui me concerne je n'y
souscris pas et je pense pas que nous le
sauverons pas sûr que votre parce que on
l'a bien vu que il y a un moment où il
faut que la parole soit respectée je
pense que là reprenez on a pour la SNCF
on l'a fait la SNCF on a changé le
système on l'a fait pour le nouveau
entrant tous ceux qui ont signé par que
quelqu'un qui rentre dans un métier sur
un métier du transport de l'énergie ou
autre qui a signé un bail qui dit je
manque dans cette carrière je gagnerai
peut-être moins qu'ailleurs je serai
peut-être moins salarié j'aurais
peut-être moins bon de conditions mais
je sais que je partirai plutôt à
l'époque etc ils ont signé revenir sur
la parole me paraîtrait alors là mais
beaucoup d'huile sur le feu dans le
débat aujourd'hui ça fait longtemps que
les républicains qui disent c'est
injuste c'est-à-dire ces régimes
spéciaux on va mettre 70 80 ans les
supprimer entre la clause du grand-père
et la durée de la retraite des gens qui
sont dans les régimes spéciaux il y a
une injustice vous entendez ça j'entends
surtout le fait que les républicains ont
été longtemps au pouvoir ils n'ont
jamais touché au régime spécial alors je
veux bien aujourd'hui être plus blanc
que blanc mais malgré tout ce
gouvernement et le premier gouvernement
qui va mettre fin au régime spéciaux et
ceux qui n'ont pas su le faire à
l'époque faudrait qu'on aille plus loin
aujourd'hui moi je pense que sur ce
sujet là j'entends bien qu'il va y avoir
une colère populaire importante qui aura
des manifestations le 7 que le pays peut
être bloqué une journée dans tout cela
gardons gardons l'esprit de
responsabilité d'équilibre et de justice
qu'il y a dans cette loi n'y touchez pas
parce que vous avez peur des blocages
vous avez peur
pour moi c'est une question de principe
les engagements de prix quelqu'un qui
rentre dans des conditions changer la
donne en cours de route c'est pas
possible mais
[Musique]